Mahomes and Josh out and I feel
like we could start nowhere
besides that, this next
generation of quarterbacks
those to continue to show how
special they can be.
Rather, let me tell you some, I
had opportunity to play against
some really, really great
special quarterback. Steve
Young,
John Elway, you know. Kurt
Warner, Peyton Manning. The
list goes on. You can go back
Dan Marino. All those guys man
and what we saw
on Sunday. Well, we were able to
witness the greatness of
these two young guys and think
about it, man. These guys are
in their low 20s. These guys are
20 something years old out
there competing
on the highest level. Like we
talked about
Competition and the spirit of
competition,
but imagine those two guys were
the two best players on
a planet at their respective
positions. And that's something
special man. Not a lot of people
can say that and to see
them out there competing seeing
out there see
them out there going toe-to-toe
and Josh Allen is an absolute
dog. Let me tell you something.
I was so disappointed in that
defense
and look I'm a patriot but I
respect the heck out of
the Buffalo Bills and I respect
the heck, but you talk about
Josh
Allen when
They need it. Most, what is he
gonna do? He's putting his body
on the line. 65 24 to 40 to 50.
He gets it done. I mean, he
could do everything. Look at
that little sidearm pass right
to Colby's Lee.
This do deserve to be in the
Super Bowl and because of that
defense because of the some
stupid mistakes and then plan A
bend, but don't break mentality
with Leslie, Frazier, and Sean
McDermott. This guy is not
playing for the AFC
Championship the way he played,
he deserved to be in the
championship game.
And if I'm Josh, Alan I am.
Absolutely sick to my stomach
right now because they deserve
to be in this game.
Thank God for the most amazing
scramble plays that I've seen
in forever. I mean, he's making
the best defenders on that
Kansas City defense. Melvin
Ingram. Maybe it's Clark on
another play. He's just making
them Miss right? He's making
a mess and he's scrambling and
then he makes the next guy
Miss. And then he set his feet.
He's ripping a throat. Me. How
about that? Two-point
conversion? Where he's buying
six extra seconds, and then
throw in a missile to the back
of the end zone. Zone. It's
amazing. So then when you
flip it to the other side of
things and you got the Kansas
City Chiefs and the Grim Reaper
that Patrick Mahomes could be,
I mean, there's 13 seconds
remaining on that clock. They
left 13 seconds. It flashes me
back to that
Bengals game where they're
going. Forget it on fourth, and
one, we're going for. There's no
we're not giving Mahomes any
chance to get the football back.
You see why? Because with
13 seconds. He can do that kind
of damage.
Yeah, with 37 seconds
defensively, if I'm
the defensive coordinator, what
I'm telling my guys is hey,
we're
going to play a soft coverage.
We're going to play a song of
coverage. Right? First of all,
I'm not I'm not kicking a ball
to these guys. But if
I do, we're not going to play a
song of coverage. We going to
get up. We're gonna Jam these
guys around a 30 yard line and
who gives them that much worse
Pace. You can't give. That's
an extra 18 yard. Now, all of a
sudden you have Kelsey
down here. You're playing soft
coverage. You don't touch him.
You don't Jam them. You got to
slow him down. In and sets up
the winning field goal.
I don't know. For the life of
me. This is the number one
defense in the National Football
League. And this is
something you practice damn
there every day you practice
this situation almost every day.
And for the Buffalo Bills, to
play, such a soft conservative
approach, Leslie. Frasier.
You've been around a game. You
you were with my 85 Superbowl
bears. Like, I respect you, but
you cannot play. Defense salt in
that situation. You gotta
get
up. You gotta Jam, those guys,
You Gotta Throw. Them off their
route. You gotta Jam them,
slalom down an extra two or
three seconds, run off the
clock, but you cannot just
drop. Let Patrick Mahomes drop
back. Let these guys
run down the field unencumbered,
you don't touch
him and then all of a sudden,
you know, now you're at home,
watching the freaking AFC
Championship game. Coming up
this weekend. It's terrible.
Jack.
Josh down because he had just
won the game time and time
again, just one impossible drive
after impossible drive
and they always ask him to do it
all himself and he just kept
doing it all himself, himself
himself. And even just watching
over there on the
sidelines, the look on his face
was just like, you just
couldn't believe that they
couldn't give him one chance.
I'll tell you. What else was
really cool rod for me was
listening to Travis Kelce.
They did the mic'd up thing,
right? Had a mic'd up that
whole final drive and his
leadership talking to Patrick
Mahomes going. Hey, first. First
of all, I had to hit that
Played a
Tyree kill, right?
It's screen that set up the next
play to Calais to put them
arranged. He tells Tyreke a
Terry start outside and then
come back under me. It will give
you the ability to get
more space. Boom. Boom. Tyree
gets all the yards. Next play
it goes and tells my home's you
guys Mahomes if they're playing
this coverage, that
seems going to be wide open
and you can hear Patrick Mahomes
right before the snap go.
Hey, Kelsey, do it, do it, do
it. If you listen close to that
game, copy Kelsey do it. Once he
do that seem, they put it
right on the money. So to see
the leadership. We talked a ton
about Patrick Mahomes and what
he means from that quarterbacks
because he does,
but they see Kelsey
in the communication and
understanding of be fences.
That's why this guy is so wide
open. It's why he's Patrick my
home's best friend.
Well, that's why this offense
works because you just can't be
a guy in this offense. They push
you mentally to know every
position. They push you mentally
to know why they're
doing certain things
why they're trying to set up,
who they're trying to set up how
they're trying to set them
up all those things. And it you
talk about Patrick Mahomes.
I really truly respect his
Because let me tell you why
coming in
when they recite their bodies
started playing that cover to.
He couldn't adjust, he couldn't
just and then finally he really
humbled himself. He took to
coaching and all aired be enemy
sent was like
just a patient, just stay
patient. If they go to keep two
safeties back, we're gonna
nickel-and-dime them to death.
And once he bought into that,
it just changed the whole meant
mentality of him. It also
changed the old mentality of the
offense. So now everyone's
saying wow, we could play cover
to, we can keep Keep them from
making a big play,
but their 12 plays 75 yards and
it's just growth not only as
a quarterback, but growth as an
offense and that's a big part
of why they're having success
in the NFL was just in such good
hands for the next decade.
You think of these two
quarterbacks. I'm looking at
the very end of that game,
when Patrick Mahomes. He's
running past teammates guys
that are just one of the most
insane NFL wins. If you go
through the history of the
league, the last four minutes
of that game, you're never gonna
find a finish.
That in the homes is running
past, his teammates,
avoiding the celebration, so
that he can go give Josh a on
this hug to show him the respect
of what he just did,
what he forced Mahomes to
overcome to get this wins. It
was the first thing you want to
do is go show that respect and
that gives you some idea
of not only the players but the
people that we have leading
the NFL right now.
Let me tell you something, man.
Just that competitive Spirit
right there just shows how
competitive both those guys are
how much Spect. They have for
one another and they both
understand how difficult it is
to play quarterback in
the National Football League.
These two dudes are very
similar. I'm sure Josh still
some stuff from Patrick Patrick
Bastille, some stuff from Josh
and these are, these guys will
be competing like you said, for
the next decade or so. So
really exciting to see
to our second takeaway, which is
Debo Samuel. You watch this
game. They just asked him to do
everything and you get you get
to see why Shanahan talk. So
highly about Debo Sam. He's
playing running back. He's
returning.
Hectic playing receiver.
So it begs the question.
Is this the best playmaker in
the NFL right now? And you look
at the versatility and things
he's able to do.
I would say best and most
dangerous definitely because
I mean like he's a big dude like
we're out there is laying like
tree trunks, like huge legs and
this dude is fast like you see
made Universe South Carolina
when I watch and play
you like. Okay, this do is kind
of fast. What is this 40 time?
And like he keeps breaking
tackles, like even against
the last week called us. He
caught a like a wide receiver
hitch. Made a guy Miss and went
20-something yards. It was just
a hitch.
Made two or three guys, miss and
went.
Only some yard. So now
as a defense you're trying to
figure out. Okay,
where's he at?
Is he at running back? Is he in
slot? Is he at the wide
receiver spot how they're going
to use them. So it puts a lot
of pressure on the defense to
try to identify them. Try to
figure out where he's at and
then trying to get him. But
yeah, he is definitely the most
dangerous because he can
do it all and he brings that
that physicality.
He gives them their identity on
an offensive side of the ball.
Then you add in Trent Williams
left tackle,
you You add in George kiddo.
And you add in Elijah Mitchell.
This is why this team is so
physical. This is a wide
receiver running over people
running through, linebackers
running through, safeties
running through corners and
everybody knows he's going to
get the ball and when he gets
the ball look at his teammates.
Blocking 10, 15 yards
down the field. He's just a very
special special player.
And when it comes contract time,
he better tell him, hey,
I'm not just a wide receiver.
I'm a playmaker. So you gonna
have to break bread
period because you have to pay
me a lot of money.
Those are the facts and when you
look at what the final four
is, it's three of the four of
quarterback driven teams,
right? You got burrow. You got
Mahomes,
you got Stafford and that for
team
is just a badass. Physical beat
you up, push you around San
Francisco 49ers team and it's
been the Kryptonite for some of
these awesome offenses, right?
It's been the Kryptonite for
the Green Bay. Packers has been
the
Kryptonite for the Los Angeles
Rams.
It it may wind up being that
again. It always feels like
this to me Rod when you get to
this point. The year and it's
cold weather football, and these
great quarterbacks. The
one thing that can neutralize is
the teams can get after
the pastor was for
in the way that the 49ers can
just bring for
and just make life miserable
on Aaron Rodgers. He's back
there. Sometimes he's trying to
scramble now. Boasts has got him
by the ankles because he's
so athletic. Those are the one
Kryptonite matchup that.
I seen, it seems like every
playoff and right now. That
team to me
feels like the San Francisco
49ers.
Will you look at San Francisco?
You look at the Rams, man, both
of those teams have. Those guys,
we witness it right?
Right there. We were first and
we looking at Aaron, we looking
at Aaron Donald we're looking at
Von Miller and those guys
and just how fast they get the
pass rush how fast they break
down at pocket protection and
and the 49ers got some big
dudes, DJ Jones, up in there.
Those guys are big. They're
athletic. They do great job of
Stuntin. They just they get
after you, man, they play
physical and those linebackers.
Oh my goodness, those
linebackers. I share and
Fred Warner. Those guys are As
their athletic, they're very
physical
and those secondary guys.
They're solid across the board.
So, it wouldn't surprise me if
San Francisco ended up in
the Super Bowl. It just wouldn't
surprise me. And this is a very
physical team.
It wouldn't surprise me. Either
you met your friend Warren.
I think Punchy had a Mercedes
Lewis to get the ball loose. He
is an instinctive linebacker
athletic. He sees it. He's so
fast. Exactly, right. So let's
get to our third take wax. We
just came out of Tampa,
right? We were up there.
We've seen the 2:32. We all know
the Atlanta Falcons story.
This was 2:53. And it never felt
like the game was over.
It's just always felt like,
Brady would have a chance, and,
of course, so many
wild moments happen, too. Where
Tom Brady can crawl back into
this thing. And now, the
question becomes after,
the loss Will Tom, Brady play in
2022. Let's hear from TB, 12.
This is what he said on his
podcast, the TB 12 podcast.
I think I'll clean it up. That's
the name of the podcast. Don't
let's go podcast. Here's what
he had to say about the
potential of his future.
I think the point is there's no
really rush for me to
figure out what's next. You
know, I'll know when I know
and it's a day after the season.
So, I think for all of
us,
you know, we can all decompress
a bit. It's been six straight
months of football every day
consumed by, you know, day in
and day out football. And I
think now, it's just some time
to
spend some time with my family
and spend some time with
my kids, the biggest difference.
Now, that I'm older is,
Kids not to, you know, and I
care about them a lot as well.
You know, they've been my
biggest supporters.
My wife is my biggest supporter,
you know, it pains her to see
me. Get hit out there.
You know, she deserves what she
needs from me as a husband, my
kids deserve what they need from
me as a dad. You know, I'm
going to spend some time with
them and give them what they
need because they really been
given me what I need
the last six months to do what I
love to do. And
you know, I said this a few
years ago. It's
what relationships are all
about.
It's not always what I want it's
what we want as a family
and, you know, I'm going to
spend a lot of time with them
and, you know, figure out
in the future. What's, what's
next.
Yeah, that's, that's really
well, said, and it's a lot to
break down. But the one thing I
want to talk about is,
you know, just those times man
are very special that you miss
in the morning with your kids.
Like I get a chance to wake up
with my daughter and my kids, my
boys,
you know, whether I fix some
breakfast or drop her off at
school. That's my five minutes.
That's my 10, 15 minutes with
her. And that's something that
you just can't get back when
you're playing football, when
you're up at 5 a.m. When you're
walking out the house by 5:15
and they don't see you until
7:00 8:00 at night.
That's those are the things that
you miss those recitals and
you know, being able to go up to
the school
and see your daughter at 12:00
and sit down and have lunch
with her. Those are the things
he's talking about. You never
get that back. Football is fine
and dandy and it's great. But
at the end of the day, you don't
get that opportunity to
take your wife out to lunch at
12:00
or 1:00 in the afternoon.
And those are very, very special
moments. And it's not
Tom's not the only
And
sacrificing your family
sacrifices a lot, too because
everything is built around your
football schedule. Everything's
built around you. So what Tom is
saying is basically as
a husband, he's like
look my family supported me
through this entire time.
Now it's time for me to spend
time with them and we figure it
out, and he's spot-on after
football, six months. You have
a lot of emotional things that's
going on in your mind
and your brain and you need
time.
But if I would, if I had to say
something, I do believe that.
Tom might give it one more shot.
He might give it one more
shot if I had to guess because I
know Tom doesn't really want
to go out the way he went out.
But I would say at the end of
the day he's going to talk it
over with his family and we'll
know soon.
You could tell for the last few
years that this was going to be
a group decision and I think Tom
is adapted his life,
the last few to make sure that
he's being, you know, having a
to
prolong life that he's spending
his time with his family
prioritizing that he's
prioritized. Football, I think
they wanted to come South. Have
a little better life, a little
better weather. All those
things. That's why I think it's
been part of this new Tom Brady
formula. If it were totally up
to Tom. I think he would
play next year. I don't think
it's totally up to Tom though.
And that's why I have no clue
what's gonna happen. But here's
to me what happened to the Bucks
this year, right? Tom
Brady came down to Tampa. He
built an All-Star team. He
built
an All-Star offense. They had a
great defense to
all some offensive line. Five
Guys, across the line who were
just studs and then The
Playmakers looked like a pro
bowl. Team, right? You had a be.
You had Godwin yet Evans
yet. Scotty Miller. They were so
deep. You
had grown yet three talented
tight ends bright. You name it?
Right? Good running backs out of
the backfield. They could
catch all those things and then
New Orleans came to town
and they rough this team up in
ways that I didn't even know
was possible. God one gets taken
out. He's done for
the season. Leonard, fournette
gets hurt in that game. That
game
just sucked the life out of this
team and then on the heels
of it, a be decides that he's
just going to go nuts.
So to me, that's what happened.
He came down, he rebuilt.
All-Star team and it just
crumbled right before the most
important point of the season.
So now does he want to go play
GM? Tom, Brady and rebuild it
all over again, perhaps he
does, but it's gonna take a
whole lot of work because my
guess is, God one
probably is not going to be
there anymore, a baby's not
going to be there. So he's going
to have to get very
creative. If he wants to rebuild
all that. It was.
You said that it crumbled man.
Ages played the divisional
game. They all they were, they
were a play away from basically
being in a sec championship, so
it didn't crumble. It's just
things happen
and that's why so hard to
let me just say it's very hard
to repeat.
What's that
saying? They got beat pretty
good, not game. I understand
you put together a miracle
comeback and nobody's better
than Brady, but they got handled
pretty darn good in
the first half of that game.
Yeah, absolutely. But all I'm
saying is this they were still
very competitive. The biggest
thing that I saw outside of
the injuries and you're spot on
Jack. You're not, you're not
wrong for what you're saying.
You're spot on actually,
but one thing that I saw, I just
saw complacency. I saw a team
that there they weren't as
hungry as they were last year.
They just weren't,
you know, you saw, you saw guys
like
Devon white doing their own
thing. Antoine Winfield came to
me before the game. I went up
and said, hey, what's the most
important thing? Got to do,
he says
well, we got to protect the Deep
part of the field because
you know, I was like, yeah, you
know Matthew Stafford is going
to take a shots down there
against you guys and what get
what happens?
They get beat for 70-yard
Touchdown, you know, by Cooper
cup it's but it's those things
and to me Tom's going to take
a look at the roster.
He's going to look at the
defense. He's going to look at
the offense and see. If is this
something that I can come back
to? Is this something that I can
compete because he's not
going anywhere else. Can we win
a championship with this? The
roster
if he believes. So I think
there's a chance that he might
but at the end of the day, I
know his wife is in that
situation where you don't want
to try to. And at the end of
the day for sure, husband to
kind of walk away from
the game, even though you might
feel like it's in his best
interest.
You know, I think he's just
going to
figure it out. But at the end of
the day,
you know, they better have Tom
Brady because if not, they
don't really have a backup
quarterback plan.
If they don't have Tom it might
be Bruce May retire. Bruce,
Arians May retire. I mean it may
just be the end of this
run. I mean, I think we all
understand get to the fourth
one
and there's no special teams
opinion. I value more than
yours because your whole career
you wanted to play special
teams. You voluntarily played
special teams, even when you
are a big named Rodney Harrison,
so
I want to hear your opinion on.
What the heck happened to
the Green Bay Packers and their
special teams. And this game
gamer to away from the Super
Bowl.
I'm blaming matloff floor mat
lafleur's the head coach and
whenever your head coach comes
in and he says, special teams
is a priority, special teams is
just as important in all our of
offense
and defense when he comes in.
And he says that, he makes it
a priority to be good on special
teams, then you know, you got
to have good special teams.
All right, and he never made
that a priority and it came
back and it bit them in the butt
and it just and they lost
games. When we were there. They
had terrible special teams.
Aaron Rodgers was so good that
they were able to overcome it.
The defense was really good. But
in times that the offense
is struggling, you need those
special teams and they have to
be good and that's Matt
lafleur's for. He should have
nipped that in the
bud and even if he's struggling,
as far as the coach, you remove
them, you replace him, you do.
Whatever you have to do to bring
them them. Special teams
up to par and I told you this, I
told you when the Chargers
played against the Raiders, how
important special teams were
and
why we as Patriots, we Here as
starters guys, plan 6570 plays
a game we volunteer because we
understood knew the importance
of field position. Making sure
that we start at the 20 yard
line as opposed to the 40 45
yard line when they only need a
couple first downs. And then all
of a sudden are in position
to kick a field goal, special
teams, man. It just can't be
offensive, can't be defense. You
have to pay attention to
everything. And that's his
inexperience as a
head coach. Not emphasizing
special teams.
It's right in the middle. Steaks
were almost everywhere
rise. The big kickoff return
Debo, Samuel had right at
the beginning of the third
quarter. Going into halftime.
They had
that field go, right? They had
that field goal as well. We're
Lancaster's play in the left
wing, and he prioritizes
the guy coming outside, and the
guy going inside, who obviously,
has a much shorter laying to get
to the kicker. He just lets
him be a
free runner and they block that
thing right before the end of
halftime. And it's those little
momentum things. I mean, this
in every single way should have
been a Packers when it
should've just been a slug. Gout
drag-out Packers win. And
it's about
the, you know, 723 2:50,
whatever, it would have been
garoppolo's not going to go all
the way down the field and
score a touchdown. At the end of
that game. The Packers
defense was playing awesome. The
one thing you couldn't have
do in the fourth quarter
was a blocked punt that lands
on. The goal line is picked up
for a touchdown is the one thing
that you couldn't have
happened. And that's how the
Green Bay. Packers wind up
losing this thing. I just think
it's
it's such a shame and I don't
know who else you could. Look
at besides the head coach. Let's
hear from LaFleur and
what he had to say after. This
one because to his credit he at
least stepped up and took the
blame.
Matt it looked like you guys had
10 guys on the field for
that final field goal attempt.
How does that happen in that
moment?
Yeah,
I can't happen.
It's unacceptable with again.
That's on me.
Yeah, it's extremely
disappointing.
Especially
we look at that. What happened
tonight?
Again, these are things I got to
do a better job, obviously,
and be more involved
to make sure that
those types of things don't
happen that we're
putting these guys in the right
position that will Coach in
the right way.
And I mean, ultimately it all
falls on me.
The fence erected does fall on
him because he's the head
coach. And he has to come in. He
has to emphasize
the importance of special teams.
And that's why I love coach
Belichick because he says, I
don't care how many pro bowls.
I mean, he all Pros. You got
if we need you to play special
teams, you're going to play
special teams. And Matt Le Flore
was so focused on
the offensive side of the ball.
He hired Joe. Barry to take care
of the defense and he kind of
just left the Special Teams out
there floating
and he's kicking himself in the
but that's why he
and that's the Appearance of
Matt Le Flore. He says, well,
I have to do a better job. I
need to be more involved. You're
damn right? You need to be more
involved. You are the head
coach. You should be sitting in
those meetings,
the Special Teams meetings,
just overlooking everything and
you should bounce your way over
to the offensive side and always
communicate with
the defensive
defensive coordinator. But you
know, and he's he understands
it now. So, next year, I
guarantee you, he will be
better in a special teams area.
I bet he will too, and it's
really a fascinating thing
because we've seen As youth
movement of coaches, right? And
even when you look at the final
four, shoot, Zack Taylor, who
the heck would have, thought
he's writing this. Think I'll
Shanahan is another young coach?
Sean
McVeigh. He's hired his low 30s,
right? And then you got
LaFleur, who's another young
coach. There's certainly been
this youth movement infused into
the NFL. And I think it
started with Mike Tomlin and it
worked there and he was
a defensive coach. And it's now
flip
to these offensive Minds to go
really teach these young
quarterbacks. What it means to
be an NFL quarterback, and it
seems to be working. So Why do
you think these young NFL
coaches are having success?
Despite what we're seeing with
LaFleur. We're in experience can
bite you, there's
both sides of that coin.
As well as take a look at their
quarterbacks.
You probably got the best
quarterbacks in the league to
write
my LaFleur. You have Aaron
Rodgers
Zack Taylor, you had a dog and
Joe burrow, like come on man.
And then Matthew Stafford, he's
proven that, I mean, we knew
Matthew Stafford can play. We
knew that he was
a tough guy, but we wanted him
to prove it on the big stage.
He's starting to prove it on a
big stage. He's got another big
stage. He has to prove it on,
but yeah, it starts with the
quarterback and where, where
would
Matt Le Flore be
right now. If he had to go with
Jordan, love,
what would he be? We wouldn't be
saying he was coach of
the year last year or, you know,
he wouldn't be in this
situation.
They probably wouldn't even make
the playoffs with him.
But when
great, it makes their job
easier. And these guys have
been given every opportunity,
you know, and let's just put it
out there. All the coaches that
your name, there was a young
white coaches. They've been
given opportunity to black
coaches, have not been given
and people have been patient
with him. Um, and it's not like
they're going to a place that
has a garbage quarterback.
These guys have, you know,
franchise, quarterbacks,
so that matters and you see like
you give air to be enemy.
Joe Borough, you give, you know,
one of those get Brian,
leverage jobber. Oh, like those
are the type of opportunities
in jobs. That
a lot of these black coaches
need, you can't just put them
on a team with no quarterback
that has to happen through this
next coaching cycle. And I do
think that there's been a bit of
a shift like Bill Belichick,
right? All the Super Bowl is you
one with him? I'm sure
he'll figure out a way to win
another Super Bowl before it's
all
said and done. But that old
style of coaching. I, you don't
see many new coaches being
hired, who are this, have
the same sort of tough way about
them when they get in front of
the team and Lead. It's now the
expectation
is that they want you to be a
player's coach and I think it
begins with where they are in
college, right? And
the transfer portal basically
every year at the end of the
season.
It's like open, you know, free
agency and everybody can go
anywhere if they're not happy or
they're not getting treated
this way. They can transfer
and then by the time they get to
the NFL
they expect that you're going to
be a player's coach. And
I think a guy like Sean McVeigh
is really one of the first that
I've seen really lock in on just
going
the respect and the friendship
and the relationships
that he builds with these
players.
It winds up resulting in them
playing and giving everything
right back to him. And I mean
you heard Odell Beckham jr.
Talked about with Chris Simms
this week, how laid-back of
an atmosphere that he created.
It's like playing in the Pro
Bowl, right? There's all these
talented players, but he makes
it laid back.
He knows that we all know what
we need to do to get ourselves
ready. And so that's work. So I
do think that it's brilliant
more about finding players
coaches right guys, that
the players are going to love
and my guess is
this next cycle of head?
Coaching hires.
I really hope that it you see a
ton of diversity. That's what
it needs to be but it results in
players coaches. Right?
Don't you get that sense that
the players have to like you
now for you to really hang on
for a long period of
time.
No, I get the sense that the
players have to respect you.
Okay, because you're not going
to always make a decision
that, you know, pleases
everyone.
But if you do it, will you do
what's in the best interest of
the team, then the players going
to respect you, and you
have to treat everybody with
respect and everybody's
a little different. You know,
you can't treat
everybody the same. Okay, you
give everyone respect but you
can't treat. Tom, Brady, the
same way you treat the 53rd
guy. You just can't do that. You
hold Tom Brady in a higher
esteem is just the way it is.
That's why.
Help 30 million dollars a year,
you know
Bay has been great. They've
given up all these future picks
and things like that. And I'm
really happy for him because
I do think he's a coach. I think
he's very passionate. I think
he's a very good coach. I think
he's very knowledgeable.
I think he
learned so much from losing a
Super Bowl
to
the coach Belichick and I'm
really excited to see what he
comes up with. I mean and you
saw you see the stamp of Sean
McVeigh like, he's been calling
some really good plays like
He's put them in a position, all
fensively
to have success. And the way
he's Incorporated old, Odell
Beckham has been tremendous for
this team
and they're hungry. Right? And
we'll get to that when we
searched almost next game, but
they're hungry, man. Obj Von
Miller Stafford. All these guys
that have never Whitworth. The
left tackle. They've never
tasted a Super Bowl, right? And
the Bucks, they had just had it
last year. So I just see them as
a lot hungrier right now,
and they're playing that way.